ก็สวัสดีค่ะพี่ๆนักเรียนน่ะสวัสดีครับนัก
เรียนเย้ก็ฟังค่ะนักเรียนมาเรียนภาษาไทย
กับเพียร์ตีกับน้องเรียนโรงเรียนอยู่ด้าน
ไหนเนี่ยอยู่นั้นนี้ที่ 25 มี
โอเคอ่านี้ใช่ไหมคะอยู่น้องเรียนอยู่ด้าน
นี้ของพี่สนธิอ่านด้านนี้ถูกต้องโอเคเรา
ชี้กันโอเค
อ้าวมาๆเรียนภาษาไทยกันวันนี้เรามาเรียน
ภาษาไทยกันวันวันอะไรครับวันนี้
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะวันนี้วันอาทิตย์วัน
อาทิตย์วันอาทิตย์อยู่ตรงไหนอยู่ตรงนี้
วันนี้อ้วนอาทิตย์แล้ววันอาทิตย์ที่เท่า
ไหร่ครับวันนี้
วันอาทิตย์ที่
12 โอนอาทิตย์ 12 แล้วแต่ไม่กลับค่ะ
วันนี้ก็
2 ใช่ไหมทำไมวันนี้ของนะครับ
อย่าตีคิดว่าคิดว่าวันนี้วันนี้เป็นวัน
ที่ 5 นะครับ
วันนี้วันที่ 5
ในประเทศไทยพูด
ในประเทศไทยวันที่ 5 วันนี้เป็นเดือนอะไร
ครับ
เดือนธันวาคมค่ะเดือนธันวาคมวันที่ 5  5
5 ธันวาคมที่ประเทศไทยเป็นวันพ่อ
เป็นวันพ่อไปอ่าเป็นวันพ่อพ่อวันพ่อใน
ประเทศไทยใช้ครับอ่ะดีที่เป็นพ่อเพื่อตี้
มีลูกเป็นก็ได้ครับพี่อะตี้เป็นข้อนี่คือ
ที่อตี้
เรียนวาดเห็นว่ารูปเรียนที่
นี่อตี้เอออ๋อ
ตัวสีขาว
ก็มีมีเออ
อันนี้
แฟนเพียบตินี่ก็มีโอ้
ๆครับมีลูกตัวเล็กๆๆ
เฮ้ยน่าเดี๋ยวลูกก็จะเรียกเขียนตี้ว่าพ่อ
ได้ครับน้า
หาเป็นพ่อพ่อพ่อ Arty เย้
แล้วก็อ่าตี้อาให้วันนี้วันนี้ก็เป็นวัน
พ่อ 5 วันพ่อในครับโอ้ฮะ
โอเคถ้า
ธันวาคมในครับวันที่ 5 ธันวาคมแล้วปีปี
นี้ปีนี้ปีคศอะไรครับปีคศ
2010  21 ค่ะ
2021 ใช่ครับแล้วปีพตอะไรครับ
พ.ต.
2564  5  2564
โอเควันนี้วันนี้วันนี้วันอาทิตย์ใช่ไหม
ครับวันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะหาแล้วพรุ่งนี้
พรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้พรุ่งนี้วันอะไรครับ
พรุ่งนี้วันจันทร์อ่ะพรุ่งนี้วันจันทร์
หน้าใช่ครับวันนี้วันอาทิตย์พรุ่งนี้วัน
จันทร์เองแล้วเมื่อวานเมื่อวานอ่าวันอะไร
ครับเมื่อวานวันเสาร์อ๋ออ๋อเมื่อวานวัน
เสาร์อาเมื่อวานวันเสาร์
วันนี้วันอาทิตย์อ่ะใช่ค่ะวันจันทร์โอเค
โอเคๆวันนี้วันอาทิตย์วันอาทิตย์หน้าอา
ตอนนี้ครับเวลาเวลากี่โมงครับกี่โมงแล้ว
ครับตอนนี้
เรียมดูนาฬิกาหน้าครับผม
6 โมง 6  10 โมง
50 ใช่ไหมอ่ะห้าสิบนาทีโอเคอ่าเป็นตอน
ตอนไหนครับตอนเช้าตอนเช้านะโอเคตอนเช้า
พระอาทิตย์ดูพระอาทิตย์เพิ่งขึ้นน่ะนิด
เดียวจ้าได้อ่ะตอนเช้าเองตอนเช้าวัน
อาทิตย์วันอาทิตย์วันอาทิตย์น้องเรียมทำ
อะไรบ้างครับวันอาทิตย์
โหโหทำไมทำไมต้องเที่ยว
โอ้ยร้องโอ้โหทำไมครับ
วันอาทิตย์ทำอะไร
ทำหลายอย่างมากๆนอนไม่ตื่นได้ไหมนอนทั้ง
วันได้ไหมได้ไหมไม่ได้หรอกทำไมทำไมนอนไม่
ได้เขา
เตรียมต้องซักผ้าขอสักผ้าอีก 555 หอ
โอเคเดี๋ยวน้องเรียนเล่าให้ฟังว่าวัน
อาทิตย์น้องเรียมทำอะไรบ้างอ่าได้ค่ะตอน
เช้าไปเลยตอนเช้าน้องริมตื่นนอนตื่นนอน
กี่โมงครับ
เรียมตื่นนอนตื่นนอน
06:00 น
06:00 น 06:00 นหน้าแสดงว่าเอ๊ยตอนนี้
6:50 ตื่นแล้วใช่ไหมครับตื่นแล้วโอเคโมง
เช้าทำอะไรอีกครับ
ก็มาคุย
เก็บที่นอนหรอกแคปที่นอนโอเคตอนเช้าตื่น
มาแล้วก็เก็บที่นอนเองอันนี้ใช่ไหมครับ
ที่นอนที่นอนที่นอนแปลว่าแต่ว่าเตียงใช่
ไหมเตียงที่นอนที่เราไปนอนขอที่นอนก็คือ
เก็บผ้าห่มอันนี้เป็นผ้าห่มใช่ไหมครับถ้า
ถือปืนใหญ่นะคืนใหญ่เป็นผ้าห่มใจ
รักซื้อมาด้วยยังไม่ตื่นเลยตื่นหรือยัง
ตื่นแล้วแล้วเอา a มันหนาว
อาเก็บผ้าห่มใช่ไหมอ๋ออ๋อผ้าห่มผืนใหญ่
ต้องเก็บเก็บ K ขำๆแล้วครับ
ที่เห็นตรงนี้ตรงนี้เป็นอะไรกับเนี้ย
หมอนค่ะอ๋ออ๋อหมอนะมีหมอนอยู่ด้วยมีหมอน
กี่ใบครับมีหมอน 2 ใบหน้าหมอน 2 ใบหน้า
เก็บผ้าห่มแล้วก็เก็บหมอน
โอเคเก็บผ้าห่มเก็บหมอนแล้วทำอะไรต่อครับ
เก็บผ้าห่มเสร็จแล้วเก็บหมอนจากน้องเรียม
ทำอะไรถ้า
เตรียมก็
มาดื่ม
ชาหอมก็ดื่มค่ะฮ่าๆๆขอดื่มชา
ช้าๆที่เห็นอันนี้อันนี้มันลอยขึ้นมาจาก
แก้วเป็น pentin ใช่ไหมขวัญของน้ำชาครีม
หอมหอมนิ่มชาอ้ออ้ออ้อว่าดื่มถ้ามึงหอม
เฮ้ยนี้นี้เป็น
สิเรียกอะไรครับ
เรียบ
เรียบหม้อชงชา
ที่เรียกอะไรคะอะไร
กากากา
ชงชา
กาชงๆครับมีน้ำชาอยู่ข้างในนี่แล้วก็เท
น้ำตาถ้าลงมาในมีแก้วช้าแล้วก็ดูเฮีย
เรียก garcons ชายปีใหม่เรียกหม้อหม้อใบ
ใหญ่ๆเดี๋ยวเราเดี๋ยวเราจะไปไหนกันใช้กับ
อันนี้เป็นกาโอเคกาชงชาแล้วน้องเรียมนาง
ดื่มดื่มชาดื่มทาแล้วทำอะไรด้วยครับเนี่ย
ทำอะไรคุยโทรศัพท์ค่ะอ๋อคุยโทรศัพท์หรอก็
มีความสุขมากเลยดื่มชาคุยโทรศัพท์นะฮ่าๆ
k5 คุยโทรศัพท์คุยโทรศัพท์กับใครครับคุย
กับใครคุยโทรศัพท์กับเพื่อนขอคุยกับ
เพื่อนฉะนั้น
โอเคได้ค่ะงานดื่มช้างคุยโทรศัพท์แล้วทำ
ก็ได้อีกครับอ่าเริ่มหิวหรือยังเริ่มหิว
เลี่ยงตอนนี้
อ้าหิวแล้วใช่ไหมอ่ะหิว
ตอนนี้เออ
ทำอะไรอยู่ครับตอนนี้ opat เห็นมีของเยอะ
แยะบนโต๊ะมีอะไรบ้างครับมีอะไรบ้างวนโต๊ะ
มี
ถือกระทะอ้านี้เป็นกระทะใช่ไหมครับมี
กระทะแล้วในกระทะมีอะไรครับเนี่ยมีไข่ดาว
ไข่ดาวไข่ดาวนี่พึ่งทอดไข่ดาวยังร้อนอยู่
มีควันร้อนไข่ดาวร้อน
ka  ka มีใครดาวแล้วมีอะไรอีกครับอ่ะ
อ่าอันนี้ก่อนคันนี้อันนี้อันนี้มีอะไร
ครับ
น้ำเปล่าหาๆนี้นะครับเปล่า
หัวเราะหัวเราะหัวเราะ
เพราะว่าบางทีว่าเป็นไม่มีเราก็ใส่น้ำ
เปล่าในเหยื่อในเหยื่อนี้มีน้ำเปล่าบางที
เราก็ใส่นมอ้าใส่นมวยไทยเหยื่อด้วยเรา
ดื่มนมตอนเช้าใช่ไหมกินไข่ดาวดื่มนมใช่
ครับน้า
ฮ่าๆแล้วก็กินน้ำเปล่าด้วยอย่าลืมกินแล้ว
โอเคเราจะมีนม
แก้วอ่อนมีแก้วนมได้ครับอ่าอันนี้เป็น
แก้วกาแฟใช่ไหมไอ้ร้านกาแฟ
any แก้วนมโอเคโอ้แล้วอันนี้อะไรครับ
เนี่ย
ตามี
นิยตอีคิดคิดว่ามันเป็นขนมปังขนมปังหาใช้
กับขนมปังแล้วก็มีง่ายขนมปังเอามากินกับ
เนยนิเนยอยู่ตรงนี้นะมีเนยอ๋ออ๋อมีไข่ดาว
ว้าวมีนี้น่าจะเป็นอะไรกันเนี่ย Stick
คิดว่าเป็นผลไม้เป็นผลไม้นะครับเนี่ยหน้า
อาจจะเป็นเรื่องคิดว่าเป็น
เกมขวัญมะเขือเทศ 6 ลูกใหญ่มากเลยโอเค
โอเคอ่ะมะเขือเทศแต่ไม่ได้หันมาใช่ไหมไม่
ได้หักมาชอบไม่ได้หักอ๋อโอเคกับกินเลยอ่ะ
อ่อตอนเช้าอ่ะลืมกาแฟคุยมากินอาหารเช้า
กินอาหารเช้าเสร็จแล้วทำอะไรต่อครับวัน
นี้วันอาทิตย์
หนู
ล้างจานอ่ากินเสร็จแล้วก็ต้องล้างจานใช่
ไหมอ๋อนี่ร้านจานน้องเรียมเปิดเปิดอะไร
ครับตรงนี้
เปิดก๊อกเปิดก๊อกน้ำมีน้ำไหลออกมานี่มี
น้ำไหลออกมามากเพื่อล้างล้างจานน้อ k  k
ล้างจานลงนี้เปิดก๊อกน้ำล้างจานมีว้าวน้า
ใครฮะโอเคครับจานจานหลายๆใบห้าตรงนี้ใช่
ไหมอ่านี่มีจานหลายๆใบอันนี้ล้างล้างหมอ
หรือยังครับล้างหรือยังล้างแล้วค่ะยอม
ล้างเสร็จแล้วล้างจานแล้วล้างอันนี้
แก้วแก้วหรอแก้วเกาะล้างแล้วใช่ไหมครับ
หลังแก้วแล้วหางจานแล้วล้างแก้วแล้วโอเค
วาวเออตอนนี้ถึงเวลาไปนอนหรือยังครับอย่า
นอนแล้วนอนได้ไหมไม่ได้เหรอยังได้ๆอ้าว
นอนไม่ได้แล้วไปไปทำอะไรอีกครับไปทำอะไร
อีก
ไปซักผ้าขอซักผ้าซักผ้าทำทำยังไงครับทำ
อะไรบ้างครับซักผ้าอันนี้อะไรครับเนี่ย
เฮ้ยเครื่องซักผ้าขอเครื่องซักผ้าน้อง
เรียมก็ไม่ได้ซักเองใช่ไหมไม่ได้ซักเอง
ใช้เครื่องซักผ้าขอให้ใช้เครื่องซักผ้า
น้องเรียมก็เอาผ้าผ้านี่ผ้าเป็นเสื้อเป็น
กางเกงนะเป็นถุงเท้าใช่ไหมใช่ข้าวอ่ะเอา
ใส่
ใส่เครื่องซักผ้าใช่ไหมครับใส่ถาดใส่
เรื่องซักผ้าขอขายผ้าเข้าไปในเครื่องซัก
ผ้าแล้วเป๊ะอันนี้นี่อะไรกับเนี่ย
ผงซักฟอกผงซักฟอก
ผงซักฟอกหรอเวลาใส่ผงซักฟอกเข้าไปใน
เครื่องซักผ้าก็จะมีฟองเหรอนี่ใช่ไหม
2 ใช่อ่าอ๋ออ๋อมาจากผมก็
ขอโอเคตัด
ตั้งค่า R  R ใส่ลงไปในเครื่องซักผ้าใส่
ผงซักฟอก
โอเคโอเคๆตอนนี้ซักผ้าเสร็จแล้วนอนได้
หรือยังครับพี่อยากไปนอนแล้วโอ้ยนอนไม่
ได้ค่ะทำไมนอนไม่ได้ครับ
ต้องรีดผ้า
ต้องรีบผ้าอีกใช่ไหมครับอ่ารีบภาพเดี๋ยว
ตีเห็นน้องเรียมกำลังรีดผ้าแล้วใช้
อะไรรีบ 5 ครับ
หายเตารีดอ๋ออ๋ออันนี้เป็นเตารีดอ่ะคนไทย
เรียกเตารีดอาใช้เตารีดรีดผ้าหารีบถ้า
แล้วอันนี้นะครับอันนี้เรียกอะไรครับอ่ะ
มาเรียมเรียกว่ากระดาน
ลองรีบอ๋ออ๋อกระดานรองรีบห้าใช่ไหมน้อ
โอเค
บางคนก็เรียกว่าโต๊ะรองรีดขอโต๊ะลองรีบก็
ได้เหมือนกันนะใช้รี่ถ้า
แล้วเวลารีบผ้าน้องเรียนต้องถามแบบนี้
ใช่ค่ะยังก็จะอยู่แบบนี้อ่าหลับหรอหลับ
หลับแล้วก็รีบผ้ารีดอ่ะรีบไปรีบมารีบไป
รีบมาแล้วหน้าถูๆก็ต้องรี่หน้าหลับไม่ได้
ใช่ครับหลับไม่ได้ต้องรีบผ้า
her โอเควาวทำหลายอย่างมากเลยทำหลาย
อย่างมากเฮ้ยเฮ้ยหมดหรือยังใครยังต้องฟัง
ไรอีกไหมยังไม่หมดอีกเหรอครับมากๆก็ทำ
เยอะมากๆเลย
เอนเดี๋ยวรีบผ้าเสร็จแล้วซักผ้าเสร็จแล้ว
อ่ะต้องทำอะไรครับ
หน้ามีอะไรให้ทำอีก
ทำกับข้าว
ว้าวหานี่ทำกับข้าวมีอะไรบ้างครับ
มีอะไรในรูปมีบ้าง
น่ะนี่เพียงตีเห็นแล้วเรียนที่เห็นเห็น
หม้อแล้วอ๋ออ้าเห็นบ่แล้วที่น้องเรียนบอก
ว่ามีหม้อได้ไหมมอบคืนนี้นี้คือหม้อหม้อ
อ้อใช้หม้อทำกับครับก็กี่ใบค่ะพี่หน้าใน
รูปนี้เพื่อตีเห็นหม้อสองใบหน้ามีหม้อใบ
ใหญ่ 1 ใบแล้วก็มีใบเล็กอีก 1 ใบรวมเป็น 2
ใบมีหม้อสองใบใจขับหาแล้วหมอก็มีมีนิอัน
นี้ครับ
นิเรียดฝาหม้อใช่ไหมครับฝาหม้อหม้อใช่
ครับโอเคไว้ปิดหม้ออ้าไว้ติดหม้อใช่ครับ
แล้วด้านล่างด้านล่างตรงนี้เป็น
ห่าเป็นเต่ายังไงครับเป็นเตาไฟมีไฟอยู่
ข้างล่างมีไฟอยู่
อะไรค่ะพอมีไฟพอมีไฟหม้อก็ร้อนใช่ไหมร้อน
ได้ค่ะแล้วก็มี
มีไอน้ำขึ้นมามีไอนัทดินมีกลิ่นหอมแอบมา
หอม
หิวข้าวทำอาหารใช่มั้ยฮะหิวข้าวเลยใช่ไหม
ใช่ค่ะ
อ๋อแล้วตรงนี้ตรงนี้อ้าเมื่อกี้เมื่อกี้
น้องเรียนบอกแล้วโรงเรียนบอกพี่เตี้ยแล้ว
ว่านี้เรียกเรียกว่าเรียกว่าอะไรครับนัก
เรียนจำได้ไหมจำได้ไหมนี้เรียกว่าอะไร
เมื่อกี้น้องเรียมใช้อันนี้ใช้อันนี้ทอด
ไข่ดาวใช่ไหมอ่าอันนี้เรียกอะไรครับหา
เรียกอะไรนะว่านักเรียนพิมพ์ไม่หน่อย
พิมพ์ในคอมเม้นให้หน่อยว่านี้เรียกว่า
อะไรอ่า
โอเค
หน้าพิมพ์เสร็จหรือยังครับพิมพ์เสร็จหรือ
ยัง
แล้วเสร็จแล้วเดี๋ยวน้องเรียมจะบอกว่ามัน
เรียกว่าอะไร
กระทะอ่ะใช่ครับมันเรียกว่ากระทะโอ้นี่
ใช้กัดฮะนะครับกระทะก็เปิดไฟเหมือนกันมี
ไฟอยู่ข้างล่างนี่กระทะก็ร้อนร้อนหนาว
โอเค
ตอนนี้ทำกับข้าวแล้วรีดผ้าเสร็จแล้วพี่
ติ๊กคิดว่าถึงเวลาที่น้องเรียมจะต้องไป
นอนแล้วไปพักได้แล้ววันอาทิตย์เย้
ครับอ่าเดี๋ยวให้น้องเรียมให้น้องเรียมไป
พักนะไม่ต้องคิดแล้วว่ารีบเสร็จแล้วเรา
ไม่ต้องรีบแล้วเฮ้ยน้องเรียมไปพักผ่อนได้
วันอาทิตย์หน้านะครับก็แล้วพี่อาร์ตี้พี่
อาร์ตี้ต้อง
ซักผ้า
รีดผ้าสาวทำกับข้าวในห้างเอทตี้ใหม่ทำ
เปียตีให้อ่าเห้ยให้อ่า
ภรรยาพี่อาร์ตี้อ๊ะ
ป่าวไม่ตีก็มาอาจวีดีโอคุยกับนักเรียนคุย
กับน้องเหลี่ยม
สิทธิ์เพียบปีให้ภรรยาได้ถ้าให้ภรรยาอ่ะ
ขำสาสถ้ารี่ผ้าำกับข้าวหน้าๆ
ขอ
โอเคอาเดี๋ยวให้น้องเรียมให้โรงเรียนไป
ซักผ้าหรือให้ไปนอน
ให้ไปนอนเลยอ่ะเตรียมโอเคนอนคะ
หาแล้วเดี๋ยวคราวหน้าเรากลับมาเรียนภาษา
ไทยกับ psd กับน้องเรียมกันใหม่นะครับใน
ช่องคอมเปลี่ยนสะโบวไทยนะเดี๋ยวให้นัก
เรียนกฎกด Subscribe กดไลค์
กดแชร์ให้ด้วยนะครับอ่ารถเกี่ยวข้าวนะคะ
กลับมาเจอกันใหม่ครับวันนี้เปียตี้
สวัสดิ์หน้าไปก่อนหาอะไรครับลาไปก่อน
สวัสดีค่ะดีค่ะพี่น้องเรียมบ๊ายบายที่ 5
นักเรียนบ๊ายบายวันอาทิตย์สารพาศรัทธารี
พา
ไปนอนดีกว่าอ่ะ